we love pie of course everyone loves pie
but one of my favorite pie facts is and
it's
i think it's fun you only need 39 digits
of pie to be able to measure the
circumference of the observable universe
within the width of one hydrogen atom
and that's all you need so we write out
the 39 digits yep
ah let's put it here so the 39 digits of
pi it's three point
now three counts is one of the digits so
it's now 38 decimal places let's do the
38 decimal places 1
1 6
5 9 7 9 three
two seven four
two
zero
he didn't memorize that everyone there
you go show everyone what you did just
in case
walt from alpha app
never leave home without it right so
he's not he's not on par you're not a
prior memorizer james no i'm not no and
that's and that's another thing
altogether people who memorize this uh
digit this pi figure to a massive amount
of digits but
people who calculate it using computers
i've calculated it to
currently
10 trillion digits of pi go on then
let's do them okay
no
so that would be all you need and that's
overkill as it is because that's all you
need to measure the circumference
of the observable universe so the
observable universe is
the the distance that light has traveled
since the big bang and if we say
travelled in a big sphere and a big
bubble then if we measure the distance
around it we'd have the circumference of
the universe
and we would need pi to work out that
circumference and we could be
as accurate as a hydrogen atom if we use
just 39
digits of pi
we don't need to use the whole thing of
course which goes on forever
so in fact in practical day-to-day use
in engineering in real life you would
only need a handful of digits of pi to
be have an accuracy that would be
suitable for anything that you need to
do so wolfe from alpha told me that the
diameter of the universe
was 8.8
times 10 to the 26 meters
so that's the diameter of the observable
universe if you want to work out the
circumference then we times it by pi
so the circumference would be pi times
the diameter
what's the difference when i take away
my truncated pi
what i mean is what if i took away
my pi with 39 digits i've called it pi
and did the same thing times by d
so that's the real circumference of the
universe take away my approximation
what's the difference
if i do that
what i got
was actually round about 2.5
times 10 to the minus 12
meters so that's how accurate that's the
difference between my approximation and
the real value that's how accurate it is
and a hydrogen atom wool from alpha told
me had a diameter of about 2.5 times 10
to the minus 11
meters so in fact this is more accurate
this is more accurate than the hydrogen
atom so why yeah why do we calculate pi
to 10 trillion digits these days it's a
way to test our computers our
supercomputers and our algorithms it's a
way to test them to see how good they
are that's why computer scientists are
interested in this sort of thing
mathematicians
are have tried to do this for
thousands of years uh out of curiosity
so it started with archimedes
uh he tried to try to
get an accurate idea of pi around about
250 bc
he didn't have decimals in those days he
had to use fractions but he had tried to
work it out
then in the 17th century
there was a dutch mathematician called
now i'll probably anglicize his dutch
name i apologize he was called ludov van
kulin
and
his life's work was working out the
digits of pi
and
by the end of his life he had worked out
35 digits of pi and on his tombstone
which is kind of cold and it's kind of
neat if you skip on to the 19th century
there was a guy who had
about 707 digits of pie this was the
authoritative example of pie for 100
years
until 1945
and they found a mistake
i know shock her they found a mistake
and the last 180 digits were wrong
because
somewhere along in his calculations
somewhere around the 500th decimal point
he had made a mistake and from that
point on everything else was wrong
what a disaster fortunately we were able
to use computers by this point
so in 1949 eniac the american computer
was able to calculate pi to 2000
digits so suddenly it just exploded
after that once we've got computers it
just exploded we had more and more
digits of pi
and now we've got 10 trillion digits of
pie